Hidy a big storyline for you in a later
season was your surgeries I had my nose
redone I had my chin shaved down I had
my breasts redone and my back shaped and
then I had a little bit of inner and
outer leg boom what was that like for
you watching this episodes I don't want
to watch it I had no idea what I was
getting into it was all having so fast
I'll definitely say women or men who
think like there's such thing as a minor
surgical procedure second somebody is
cutting your body it no longer becomes
minor everyone else in the show is in
the clubs and dealing with this knot we
were dealing with like life-threatening
severe things we were just emotionally
empty and spent at that point and we
just really needed support instead of
continuing to be cut down by everyone
coming here and having you attacking me
it's just really hard it was the hardest
time of my life and I feel like I've
become a lot stronger from it and I
certainly made me look at myself you
know and reflect why did I do that and
why did I feel like that was a good
decision and not to be so impulsive and
I think that I just became so consumed
by this character that I was playing
that it kind of became that girl and I
lost track of like this small-town
Colorado girl who really did I just love
a simple life I like nature I like
different things and I just kind of
became consumed in a different world but
I certainly wouldn't do it again and I
certainly wouldn't recommend it and I
have learned a lot from it and I just
want to move forward in a in a positive
way I loved Heidi pre-surgery you know I
was loved her so much I love Heidi
poster you know like I fell in love with
Heidi's dancing so the surgery did not
affect me dance man
you